[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
j'ai plaisir de la présenter avec steve
jourdain bonjourbonjour elsa et cette
semaine on revient sur un passage obligé
pour tout premier ministre la
déclaration de politique générale et on
en parle avec notre invité le sénateur
la république en marche des
hauts-de-seine xavier iacovelli bonjour
bonjour et c'est steve qui dresse votre
portrait xavier iacovelli vous êtes né à
suresnes dans les hauts-de-seine vous
est l'aîné d'une fratrie de quatre
enfants produit d'une famille de
descendants d'immigrés italiens arrivés
en france à la recherche d'une vie
meilleure vous avez longtemps été chef
d'une entreprise de restauration
la politique elle débute réellement
pourvoi l'âge de 21 ans 21 ans le front
national est au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle vous décidez
de vous engager au parti socialiste
premier mandat d'élu local à suresnes en
2008 juin 2015
vous êtes élue premier fédéral dans les
hauts-de-seine septembre 2017 vous
donnez sénateurs toujours sous les
couleurs du parti socialiste
mais patatras l'année dernière fin de
votre histoire avec le ps à l'été alors
que votre groupe décide de voter contre
le discours de politique générale
d'edouard philippe vous vous abstenez et
finalement vous céder aux sirènes du
nouveau monde vous rejoignez le groupe
en marche au sénat il a dit à copé y est
ce que le charme opère toujours à ce
qu'il est possible d'avoir le coeur à
gauche comme vous l'avez et d'être
séduits par ce gouvernement castex oui
bah là la preuve c'est que moi je me
revendique eux toujours un homme de
gauche mais un gauche de gouvernement
une gauche pragmatique une gauche pour
moi la gauche si la gauche de progresser
celle qui réforme c'est pas celle qui
qui s'opposent systématiquement et qui
fait du conservatisme
donc c'est vrai que je me suis abstenu
lors du discours de politique générale
d'edouard philippe en juin 2019
notamment parce qu'il y avait une vision
et un objectif sur la question
écologique déjà à l'époque qui a mis du
temps il faut se le dire entre nous je
suis quelqu'un de libre aussi donc dans
ma parole qui a mis du temps à venir
mais donc du coup j'ai voulu on va dire
donner une chance sur cette nouvelle
nouvel acte du
du quinquennat avec edouard philippe en
m'abstenant ce qui a provoqué
effectivement un certain nombre d'
attaques de ma famille politique pour
une fille n'est que je quitte le parti
socialiste en octobre 2019 au moment où
j'ai signé la tribune des des
parlementaires et et anciens
parlementaires socialistes qui appelait
à soutenir le président de la république
notamment aux côtés de jean-yves le
drian et d'olivier du soft et c'est à
partir de ce moment là où je suis devenu
secrétaire général du mouvement
territoire de progresser dans la
majorité présidentielle nouveau
gouvernement n'est pas trop à droite
pour vous non mais en plus souvent dans
le en même temps m la réalité c'est
comme quand on regarde la composition du
gouvernement
on a aujourd'hui plus de deux ministres
qui viennent de la gauche
on a plus de ministre qui viennent de la
gauche on a un petit peu moins de la
droite et on a une grande partie aussi
qu'il est les patients très importants
comme l'économie l'intérieur ce sont des
ministres de droite est d'accord mais
enfin ce qui est important ce n'est pas
le casting ce qui est à vous parler du
casting effectivement on parle d'un
gouvernement mais ce qui est important
c'est la politique qui est mise en place
aujourd'hui moi si on parle du casting
effectivement aujourd'hui il ya plus de
représentants qui viennent de la gauche
et ce qui d'ailleurs est l adn de la
république en marche c'est à dire ceux
en même temps où un certain nombre de
soutiens de françois hollande de 2012 se
sont retrouvés dans le soutien d'
emmanuel macron en 2010 est donc c'est
aussi cet adn qui est important de
garder et on va parler ajustement de la
politique on passe à présent au sommaire
de cette émission 345 voix pour 177
comptait 43 abstentions l'assemblée
nationale a accordé sa confiance au
premier ministre jean castex tu dans sa
déclaration de politique générale devant
les députés le premier ministre a promis
de ressouder la france c'est en ami sus
de la ruralité et des territoires que
jean castex et présenté devant les
sénateurs il ya prononcé un discours de
politique générale axée sur le thème de
la décentralisation l'entendra et puis
le budget rectificatif de crise examiné
cette semaine au sénat c'est le
troisième budget d'urgence pour faire
face à la crise tamise
allez on commence avec le grand oral de
jean castex à l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était mercredi dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale la déclaration de
politique générale de jean castex les
députés lui ont largement accordé leur
confiance
343 345 voix pour 177 contre et 43
abstentions pendant une heure jean
castex a détaillé sa feuille de route
avec sa méthode et la volonté de
réconcilier les français les précisions
de rabbi cas l'ambition est de taille
pour le nouveau premier ministre
réconcilier la france et les ya beaucoup
de france qui se sentent loin et laissé
pour compte
phrase des banlieues france rurale
français d outre-mer france dit
périphériques france de ceux y compris
au coeur de nos villes n'ont pas droit à
la parole et ce sera notre première
ambition immense réconcilier ces france
si différentes les souder ou les
ressouder ressouder la france mais aussi
renouer le dialogue social avec les
corps intermédiaires le dialogue
l'écoutent la recherche du compromis
voilà les leviers d'une démocratie
apaisée
je crois j'ai toujours cru aux vertus du
dialogue social en pleine crise la
relance économique et la priorité du
gouvernement
avec une nouvelle méthode le contrôle
100 milliards d'euros seront investis
dans l'emploi la transition écologique
et l'inde huîtres le gouvernement
présentera tous les deux mois un point
précis de la mise en oeuvre de ce plan
de relance de ses impacts et de ses
résultats
parmi ces investissements 20 milliards
d'euros seront consacrés à l'écologie
cette bataille que le gouvernement dit
vouloir gagner
alors avant le fonds va parler un peu de
la forme et de la personne on a beaucoup
commenté le fait que le président de la
république remplacer finalement un
énarque de droite par un autre énarque
de droite jean castex il incarne quoi le
changement
la continuité la continuité dans le
changement le changement dans la
continuité
non je pense qu'ils incarnent les
territoires il incarne cette
décentralisation c'est une nouvel acte
de la décentralisation voulue par
président de la république pour donner
aussi plus de pouvoir et plus de
responsabilité aux collectivités
territoriales en moi en tant que
sénateur je ne peux que m'en satisfaire
c'est vrai que c'est une autre façon de
s'exprimer une autre façon peut-être
peut-être plus pédagogique même si
j'avais beaucoup d'estimé pour pour
edouard philippe qui était peut-être
parfois un peu cassant avec un certain
nombre d'opposants mais je pense que
jean castex et il l'a rappelé est apaisé
la france faire en sorte de reprendre
aussi ce dialogue social qui qui avait
qui existait un soulier d'or philippe
mais qui qui avait peut-être été un peu
rompus au moment des grèves
donc je pense que moi en tant que social
démocrate votant dire que le directeur
philippe mais ils l'ont dit edouard
philippe
et le président de la république la
république l'a d'ailleurs redit non lors
de son discours pour pouvoir incarner un
nouveau cap dans le quinquennat il
fallait changer aussi de premier
ministre et ça c'est d'un commun accord
entre d'anciens premiers ministres le
président de la république on peut pas
changer de cap faire un virage social et
écologiste sans avoir un changement de
l'équipe
vous le voyez ce virage vous le voyez
clairement ce virage social et
écologique mais moi je le vois notamment
sur la question de la jeunesse qui est
un indispensable quand on voit qu'on à
700 milles à huit cent mille jeunes qui
vont arriver sur le marché de l'emploi à
partir de septembre et qu'on n'avait pas
de solution à lorsqu'on en pleine crise
économique
pleine crise sociale effectivement les
propositions aujourd'hui qui sont sur la
table lors du discours de politique
générale qui est dont une partie
d'ailleurs on vont être mis en oeuvre
dans le projet de loi de finances
rectificative vous dans ce sens là on
soutient justement à cette jeunesse pour
qu'il n'y ait pas une jeunesse sacrifiée
comment on pouvait s'y attendre
pourtant il ya certains parlementaires
qui ont votre parcours d'anciens
socialistes qui ne s'y retrouvent pas
aujourd'hui ils disent on va continuer
avec la réforme des retraites on va
peut-être demander des efforts aux
français
pour eux le virage écologiste socialiste
n'existe pas quand le coup le premier
ministre indique
il veut réindustrialiser la france fer
de que la réindustrialisation de la
france passe aussi par la transition
écologique moi c'est ça que je vois moi
je vois aussi une volonté aujourd'hui
d'aller sur cette transition écologique
quand je vois effectivement les
milliards que nous mettons sur la table
pour soutenir la jeunesse pour quand on
voit le plan ségur qui est un plan bien
sûr jamais satisfaisant pour ceux qui
subissent au quotidien les le manque de
financement de l'hôpital mais 8
milliards pour la revalorisation des
carrières 6 milliards d'investissements
dans les villes et dans les hôpitaux
voilà c'est aussi ça c'est aujourd'hui
des mesures inédites
la dernière fois qu'on a revalorisé le
personnel je crois que c'était un grand
plan d'envergure c'était rocard en 91
je veux dire il ya quand même trente ans
on n'a rien fait pour le personnel
soignant donc c'est effectivement des
mesures inédites des mesures sociales et
des mesures indispensables aujourd'hui
on va revenir un peu plus tard sur
effectivement ce plan de relance
économique mais puisque vous parliez
d'écologie il y a eu
nicolas hulot il ya eu françois de rugy
maintenant barbara pompili est-ce
qu'elle va pouvoir réellement agir on
dit que le ministère de l'écologie c'est
un peu le ministère maudit je pense pas
aujourd'hui elle est numéro deux du
gouvernement s'est aussi de montrer que
que cette question est centrale dans la
politique du gouvernement
elle vient aussi de la gauche elle vient
des écologistes mais de la gauche
aujourd'hui du gouvernement elle est
d'ailleurs membre d'un d'un mouvement au
sein de la majorité présidentielle et
d'une sensibilité au sein de l hérault m
qu'ils s'appellent en commun qui assume
ce côté social démocrate et écologiste
d'ailleurs nous on a des discussions
entre territoires de progrès et avec
l'ailé gauche de la majorité
donc non je pense qu'au contraire elle
est là la volonté d'agir et je pense
surtout qu'il ya une prise de conscience
de l'ensemble de nos dirigeants sur
cette question écologistes et je pense
qu'il est indispensable aujourd'hui que
toutes nos politiques publiques et ce
fil rouge de la transition écologique
justement il faut bercy suivent par
exemple il n'ya pas que le ministère de
l'écologie il ya l'économie aussi oui
mais bien sûr mais bercy suivra
lorsqu'il y aura des arbitrages de
matignon et aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'il ya une volonté du premier ministre
des finances est dans cette croissance
verte et dans et non pas dans cette
décroissance écologique vous avez repris
à les termes du premier ministre
le premier ministre qui a d'ailleurs
renouveler l'exercice de la déclaration
de politique générale cette fois devant
le sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faudra sans doute dans les mois qui
viennent s'habituer à entendre le mot
territoire à l'assemblée nationale jean
castex avait déjà beaucoup mis en avant
devant le sénat pour son discours de
politique générale il a détaillé sa
vision pour un nouvel acte de la
décentralisation regarder ce sujet les
signer jonathan du prix y est ce que le
premier ministre vous avez la parole
jean castex a envoyé aux sénateurs un
signal attendu face à eux pendant deux
heures et demie il s'est posé en premier
ministre des territoires territoire le
mot a d'ailleurs été prononcée 30 fois
par l'ancien maire de prades
ils seront donc logiquement la pierre
angulaire de sa politique laitages lady
est le garant des fonctions régaliennes
qui c'est l'unité de la nation
mais pour l'ensemble des grains de
transition écologique économique et
sociale les acteurs territoriaux doivent
être à la manoeuvre devant la chambre
haute jean castex a aussi tenu à
s'adresser particulièrement aux élus
locaux et a salué leur engagement
pendant la crise les élus ont été
remarquables d'implication et de
dévouement a commencé à commencer par
les maires qui ont comme toujours été
combattants de la première ligne et de
la première heure lors de son discours
jean castex a surtout longuement
détaillé sa vision en matière de
décentralisation vision largement
convergente avec celle du sénat le
locataire de matignon souhaite accélérer
la marche via le projet de loi dit 3d et
délégué aux collectivités davantage de
compétences notamment en matière de
santé
je souhaite à cet effet que les régions
les départements et les
intercommunalités puis se prendre une
part plus grande dans la gestion de
notre système de santé qu'elle puisse si
elles le souhaitent s'associer aux
investissements que nous allons y
décider jean castex a aussi confirmé la
tenue prochaine d'une conférence
nationale des territoires ainsi que la
présentation en conseil des ministres
avant la fin du mois d'un projet de loi
organique ouvrant le droit à la
différenciation permettant aux
collectivités davantage
d'expérimentation
niveau local xavier iacovelli il n'y a
pas eu de vote au sénat sur cette
déclaration de politique générale
j'imagine que vous l'auriez voter cette
confiance oui oui je l'aurais voter bien
sûr sans réserve
d'ailleurs je peux regretter que
qu'aujourd'hui on s'assoit pas
obligatoire de faire un vote au sénat
que ce soit seulement une volonté du
gouvernement je pense qu'il faudrait
prendre cette habitude a refusé
justement selon vous de jeu je pense
sincèrement je ne pense pas qu'il y
avait un risque parce que ce sont le
vote du sénat n'est pas contraignant et
ne ne peux pas faire tomber le
gouvernement comme c'est le cas à
l'assemblée nationale mais je pense
qu'il n'y avait pas forcément une
utilité à le faire moi je le regrette
parce que je pense effectivement qu'il
ya nécessité qu'aujourd'hui les
parlementaires qu'on soit au sénat ou à
l'assemblée puis se positionner sur un
discours de déclaration de politique
générale du premier ministre
bon c'est pas la constitution ne
l'obligent pas la constitution ne le
gouvernement n'a pas souhaité engager
les sénateurs de droite aura été un
petit peu gêné à l'idée de beauté à
votre aliment quand on a un premier
ministre qui vient dans la chambre haute
celle qui représente les territoires et
quand on dit trente fois à 30 reprise
territoire le mot territoire le mot il
faut un nouvel acte de la
décentralisation donner plus de
responsabilités plus de pouvoirs aux
élus locaux
je rappelle que jean castex et celui que
ce qui a mis en place la doctrine
lorsqu'il était monsieur déconfinement
la doctrine du binôme maire préfet qui a
vraiment fonctionné sur cette partie du
déconfinement et qui a aidé nos
concitoyens dans la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
donc on voit bien qu'il ya cette volonté
d'élus rural d'élu local de pouvoir
reprendre aussi la main sur les
territoires justement territoire
territoire territoire on l'a entendu
vous l'avez dire à 30 reprises c'est des
sauts de cabri ou vraiment jean castex
et sincère dans sa volonté de renouer
avec les collectivités locales
mais je pense qu'il est sincère de par
son parcours encore une fois il était
lui maire d'une ville de 6000 habitants
conseiller départemental on voit bien
qu'il ya cet ancrage local dans la
ruralité et donc il connaît la réalité
des territoires des collectivités
territoriales et donc je pense que c'est
sincère
et d'ailleurs je pense que ça a été la
feuille de route et l'accord qu'il ya eu
entre le premier ministre et le
président de la république lorsqu'il a
été nommé à matignon
c'est ce qui a péché selon vous pendant
les trois premières années du
quinquennat on a eu le sentiment d'une
déconnexion entre paris et ce qu'on
appelle les territoires le reste de la
france finalement coûté moi je c'est
difficile parce que j'étais dans
l'opposition pendant au moins les deux
premières années du quinquennat donc
c'est vrai que moi j'ai estimé
ne serait-ce qu'en 2017 lorsque j'ai
fait ma campagne sénatoriale je trouvais
effectivement qu'il y avait eu une
déconnexion de l'elysée de l'équipe
autour du président sur la réalité des
territoires la réalité des élus locaux
qui je me rappelle aussi aux gens y
avait une petite attaque un peu sur les
élus locaux où il ya 85 % des élus
locaux qui ne sont pas indemnisés et
donc ils font ça vraiment bénévolement
au service de leurs concitoyens et donc
moi je pense effectivement que dans un
premier temps il ya eu un petit peu a
loupé sur les élus locaux qui s'est
vraiment ensuite edouard philippe a
vraiment repris la main dessus et là
jean castex clairement montre que les
territoires sont font partie intégrante
de notre république et qu'il est
important pour notre politique nationale
d'avoir des territoires fort on nous
promet un nouvel acte de la
décentralisation
quand vous voyez par exemple ce qui
s'est passé en italie le pays de vos
ancêtres notamment en matière sanitaire
ça vous inquiète pas une nouvelle
décentralisation
non moi je pense sincèrement qu'on
contraire les élus locaux sont en
proximité et connaissent en matière de
santé nam et connaissent aujourd'hui
leur territoire les problématiques
après moi je pense effectivement qu'en
termes de santé il est important d'avoir
un cadrage national d'avoir des
directives nationales est d'avoir une
coordination nationale après que les
investissements soit décentralisée que
les administrations associe les les élus
locaux ce qui est déjà le cas dans un
certain nombre d'hôpitaux de province je
le rappelle
y compris de région parisienne donc moi
je pense qu'il est important de
décentraliser un maximum et que d'un
point de vue national on puisse garder
cette coordination de santé est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui les ars c'est ça
c'est une décentralisation du des
pouvoirs de santé également quand on
parle également de différenciation on
al'impression l'inquiétude parfois d'une
rupture d'égalité on se dit pas si on
est dans une région riche finalement on
va avoir de la chance mais pour les
régions un peu moins riches
finalement on n'aura pas des
expérimentations comme les autres non je
pense que les expérimentations ce n'est
pas seulement dû à la richesse des
territoires je pense qu'il ya
effectivement des des spécificités
région par région
je pense que c'est important de pouvoir
avoir cette différenciation après il
faut que ce soit limité parce que je
rappelle que la république est une et
indivisible et qu'aujourd'hui il n'est
pas question d'avoir des république
autonome et et une france fédérale mais
je pense qu'il ya une différenciation
sur la culture sur le nos services
publics qui doivent être à mon avis
aussi beaucoup plus décentralisée est
sûre au plus près de nos concitoyens
j'aimerais vous faire écouter cet
extrait de jean castex au sénat une de
ses sorties a provoqué quelques
moqueries écouter le plan de relance
portera une attention particulière aux
pistes cyclables on m'a manqué quand
j'ai 10 1 à 10 il parle d'un gadget
pas du tout mesdames et messieurs
sénateurs pas du tout pas du tout et
nous sommes à une révolution c'est le
vélo électrique
il va multiplier les usages il va
multiplier les usages il va raccourcir
les distances oui oui mesdames et
messieurs oui mesdames et messieurs ne
riez pas ne riez pas dans dix ans dans
dix ans on pourra si on fait un réseau
de pistes cyclables sécurisées on pourra
aller de prades à perpignan un vélo pour
aller travailler
voilà prades perpignan ça correspond à
peu près à suresnes rambouillet en vélo
électrique c'est faisable le matin pour
aller au boulot je pense que c'est
faisable je pense que certains font déjà
ce genre de distances on l'a vu pendant
les grandes grèves de la fin d'année
2010 9
on l'a vu pendant la période de
déconfinement il ya eu vraiment les
français ont voulu reprendre ce moyen de
transport qui n'est pas un nouveau moyen
de transport mais pour le coup c'est
inédit dans sa dans sa prise en charge
avait plus + 29% je crois de de
transport en vélo pendant cette
période-là donc moi je re contraire je
ne pense effectivement que c'est pas un
gadget je pense que c'est vraiment une
mobilité d'avenir et dont les pouvoirs
publics doivent se se saisir allez on
accélère nos os il nous reste une
poignée de minutes pour parler
d'économie les sénateurs se penchent en
ce moment sur le budget rectificatif
c'est le troisième depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup trop peu beaucoup trop tard les
sénateurs considèrent que le budget
rectificatif actuellement discuté à
l'automne assemblée n'est pas assez
ambitieux ils demandent davantage de
mesures de relance économique samia de
chiens plus la crise s'annonce profonde
plus le gouvernement allonge les
milliards
36 de plus dans le nouveau budget
rectificatif ce qui porte le plan
d'urgence à 462 milliards d'euros au
total une somme nécessaire mais mal
fléché pour les sénateurs plus qu'un
plan d'urgence il réclamait un vrai plan
de relance de l'économie
initialement prévu pour ce troisième
budget rectificatif
il est finalement reportée au projet de
loi de finances 2010 21
nous ne sommes pas en désaccord avec vos
mesures d'urgence et de soutien
ce texte que nous ne passe pas
difficultés nous allons l'améliorer mais
nous sommes plutôt en désaccord avec ce
qui n'est pas dans le texte puisque nous
pensons qu'il faut faire autrement dit
faire mieux
nous en reparlerons mais il nous semble
surtout que des mesures de relance de
votre prise dès maintenant et non à
l'automne pour confus que pour confirmer
pour aider les français à retrouver la
confiance pour introduire des mesures de
relance la commission des finances
propose à travers ces amendements de
mettre en place des chèques loisirs pour
6 millions de ménages modestes ou encore
de flécher les pannes des particuliers
vers les entreprises
autre reproche des sénateurs à ce
nouveau budget rectificatif l'absence de
financement on dit qu'on va financer par
la dette et qu'on va mettre la dette de
côté mais mettre la dette de côté ça ne
la fait pas disparaître y arrive un jour
où elle vous rattrape seulement ça ne va
pas être sur cette génération ça va être
sur les suivantes
c'est un manque de courage politique en
tout plus de mille amendements ont été
déposés
c'est donc une version très modifiée du
budget rectificatif qui devrait sortir
de l'examen au sénat il avait lié à ces
deux mesures de relance dans ce texte je
pense que on l'a dit 1 462 milliards qui
ont été mis en relance de plus en
soutien et en l'ancien leur soutien et
en relance forcément parce que le
soutien permet aussi la relance quand on
a 12 millions de
nos concitoyens qui ont été accompagnés
par un chômage partiel c'est aussi un
soutien aux entreprises pour leur
permettre de se relancer à cendres et de
ne pas sombrer et de repartir aussi avec
des bases plutôt saine à partir de
septembre
donc effectivement il ya une nécessité
moi j'ai vu aussi que le gouvernement
avait repris un de mes amendements que
j'avais mis au point fr 2 notamment pour
le soutien aux plus faibles aux 18 25
ans c'était des coups pour pour les
prêts les jeunes précaires c'est aussi
80 millions d'euros qui ont été mis en
place pour pour financer cette aide
je pense que tout ça c'est des aidants
de soutien effectivement qui sont
importants après il ya une stratégie
effectivement sur la réindustrialisation
de de la france qui passe par la
transition écologique
ça va créer aussi de l'emploi et je
pense qu'effectivement il ya le
gouvernement a une volonté d'investir
dans la transition écologique pour faire
sous plan de relance sur les aides aux
entreprises il y à un débat est ce qu'il
faut les conditionner ou pas les
conditionné au respect de
l'environnement
au fait de ne pas licencier est ce que
pour vous le gouvernement doit mettre
plus de conditions quand on aligne les
milliards moi je suis d'accord pour
avoir un certain nombre de conditions je
n'ai toujours rien n'a pas beaucoup en a
mais je vous dise que moi je pense parce
que le gouvernement a dit moi je pense
effectivement qu'il faut un peu plus de
conditions et notamment
alors passez sur l'interdiction des
dissensions parce que je ne crois pas à
l'interdiction de licenciement sinon on
peut faire aussi couler l'entreprise
mais c'est vrai que lorsqu'on a des
aides publiques pour la relance ce n'est
pas pour reverser sur des dividendes
pour les actionnaires c'est aussi pour
relancer réinvestir dans l'économie et
réinvestir et sur sur l'économie de leur
propre entreprise qu'il faut des
sanctions il faut des sous ils font des
contrôles surtout avant d'avoir des
sanctions sur des contrôles et je pense
qu'effectivement il faut que la loi
puisse fixer un certain nombre de
limites et notamment n'ont pas
l'interdiction des licenciements mais
que les licenciements soient justifiées
et on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans un certain
nombre d'entreprises où on était passé
je ne sais plus laquelle entreprise mais
on était passé de 1300 licenciements
prévus à après une négociation avec les
services de l'état à 500 réel
licenciements économiques très très
rapidement peut-être le plan de relance
on parle de 100 milliards d'euros qui va
payer pas qui a payé aujourd'hui c'est
la dette donc forcément c'est les
français infiné
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut créer de
nouvelles recettes trouvait aussi des
moyens de financement c'est vrai qu'au
niveau au niveau européen on va aussi
avoir ses aides importantes ce plan de
relance européen négocié notamment avec
angela merkel et le président macron ce
week end vont être décisifs très
rapidement sur la taxe d'habitation la
suppression pour les 20% des ménages les
plus aisés ce qu on la remet à plus tard
c'est ce que le président a estimé aller
dans le bon sens je pense
qu'effectivement après faut voir d'un
point de vue constitutionnel si c'est si
c'est possible mais je pense
effectivement que ça peut permettre de
soulager un peu les finances de l'état
merci iacovelli ce sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup elsa on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo
[Musique]